[Music]
season two is finally here yes when you
got your hands on that first script what
was your reaction was was yes finally we
love the show
and we particularly love the writing we
love to work with one another
we're also curious like I think a lot of
people are as to where you know where
we're going with all this so yeah it was
uh it was great but the funny thing was
for me was that within the first three
weeks of filming I was just shooting
scenes from maybe five or six different
episodes without having read I read the
entire script so I was trying to feel my
way around much like you know Bernard my
character in the beginning of the of the
season is trying to figure out where
exactly am I you know well where would
do we pick up with Bernard Bernard is in
a pretty vulnerable place the world has
been blown apart part of his head has
been blown apart and then he shot
himself toward the end of season one so
he's he's he's not as clear of mind as
he might want to be considering that you
know there's chaos all around so he's
asking himself you know where am I in
all this where's this going where is
this going and how do I get there
he's got questions but no answers I
think like you know like our audience
will have at the beginning of the season
so Bernards right there with you what
was your number one leftover question
from season one what next
yeah that's my you know that's that's
it's it's such
the the premise is is the premise behind
Westworld offers almost infinite
possibilities and so the question
becomes what are we gonna do with this
how are we gonna use this this this idea
and we're where we gonna go with it so a
few of those questions are answered in
season two there were some reveals some
surprises in season one and there'll be
some more in season two but I'll tell
you this though I went back and watched
the pilot the first episode a couple of
weeks ago if you go back and watch the
pilot there are some windows there okay
on to season two so make sure you do
that now LC is back this season which I
was surprised to see because Bernard was
kind of under the impression he may be
killed her yeah will we see them
interact is she back
I guess it's never safe to assume
anything on this show
right you know yeah better better not to
assume anything well in line with
assumptions it seems like Ford is gone
for good
mm-hmm how does that impact Bernard Ford
took a took a bullet and you know
Bernards got a robot brain you know
Ford's human brain didn't survive that
so for Bernard that means you know a new
type of freedom and new type of
responsibility but it's obviously
something that he's got to to take on
board because you know Ford was his
creator and so that's it's you know his
his Bernard is in between extremes
does he have allegiance to this memory
of Ford does he despised him for the
things that he's put but how do you
despise the thing that's created you
right do I had to do I have allegiances
to the humans or to the hosts
and where am I in all of this and then
that's all kind of compounded by the
fact that you know things aren't really
working inside his robot brain as as he
might want them to work so yeah there's
a lot too there's a lot for him to
figure out and yeah and his and his
capacity to figure that figure those
things out is diminished if you had to
sum up season two with just one word
what would that word be fire fire I'll
take it it's just if if season one is a
was a bit of a slow burn season two is
jet fuel fire ablaze I will take a blaze
[Music]
[Applause]